it is time for a battle of the bites yes
the wave donut shop of course will claim
the coveted battle of the bites trophy
and it doesn't that's right get any
better than that
[Music]
what makes a perfect donut for you
okay what i'm looking for in a donut i'm
looking for a real nice
soft uh moist cake uh
i i'm looking for uh the any kind of
glaze
to uh have a nice hold on it not when
you take a bite have it fall off right
away
and above anything i'm looking for
flavor
well up first is from your home
town of chicago it stands donuts
hey drew knight rachel aviola here from
stands domestic coffee in chicago
thanks so much for including us today
stance has 13 locations in chicago
we also ship via gold belly nationwide
all the donuts are handcrafted made with
real eggs butter and vanilla and a
little bit of love
hope you all enjoy it okay let's try
stand donuts all right we have which one
uh
the green one oh my gosh it looks like a
pistachio
possibly lemon pistachio oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh
yeah this one's all about the texture
right it's like crunchy on the outside
but still moist
on the inside donut let me eat all of
these
now i may be an old-fashioned kind of
guy
but this is like a perfect cake doughnut
and i'm not even a pistachio person
but that flavor is just beautiful it's
beautiful oh my god it's like you said
you wanted cake
but it feels like it's been deep fried
yeah i'm gonna try the chocolate glaze
which by the way
is giving me like full-blown hostess
ding-dong
yes yes i thought that i thought
ding-dong here we go
oh ding-dong
i think the texture is perfection okay
wow all right up next we have hero
donuts from birmingham
alabama take a look my name is will
drake founder
owner hero donuts hebrew donuts started
uh from
honestly from memories of my dad and i
getting fresh hot doughnuts
every sunday after church south georgia
was ready to open up my own business i
knew that it had to involve donuts
here we are today we have stores in
birmingham atlanta
one in charleston opening a couple
months we source all of our ingredients
there's no donut mixes we make
everything from scratch
uh they're fluffy and they're awesome
okay i feel like i might need to take a
bite of both
like the chocolatey sprinkle one and
this like great glazed crawler thing
what what are these does anyone know
well i can tell you this this is for
sure some kind of fritter
yeah this is like an apple fritter maybe
i'm gonna take a bite of it right now
um this is the chocolate glazed side
yup oh my god oh god the apple juice
did you get the apple apple fritter is
incredible
oh my god the burst of the fresh fruit
in there so good
i'm i'm going to chocolate town real
quick hold on okay we'll see you there
i went to chocolate town and it was like
that kid's birthday cake feel where
it's like sometimes when you go too
fancy you can never stay that tried and
true they nail it with this
these are incredible hero donuts is
amazing all right we're gonna
go to guru donuts last but not least
we've got guru donuts from boise idaho i
love idaho take a look
guru donuts started out of a garage with
a donut fryer and a dream
to serve others and create community
through the joy of the shared donut
experience
we are proud to be a woman woman-owned
and women-led business
and value creating a fun and welcoming
environment for everyone we know you're
gonna love our donuts because our motto
is donuts for all we make
vegan and gluten-friendly options
including our idaho potato donut our
donuts are made with real ingredients
you can pronounce
locally sourced nothing artificial we
mix cut
fry and glaze each donut by hand every
morning no shortcuts
um i'm so excited idaho potato
what and do you see this donut is a
square donut
breaking the rules and it's called the
winnie the pooh
that's the winnie the pooh ike should we
try it should we try it
yes very much i've never had a square
donut oh my god
oh yeah i know oh my god whoa
i was not expecting this very doughy
um very bready but very moist
not dry whatsoever no and complex
complex it's not too sweet it's like a
buttermilk biscuit and a donut
had sex and made this beautiful child
and then this one is the mango tango
okay this one oh my god i know the
cinnamon
the mango tango what cinnamon what do
you think did you try that one
i just took a bite of that mango i've
never had a mango donut
i feel alive
oh wait this is the gluten-free one with
the potato flour hold on
all right this is this one right here
this guy whoa
what oh my god i think whoa i think kids
would love this it's like very
sprinkly sparkly candy like you're
eating like
candy diamonds okay guys now it comes
time
um to vote um
one at a time we're gonna reveal our
favorites
all right ready i'm gonna go first a one
a two
a three okay
uh i'm gonna go second i'm gonna vote
for
gurus
chicago idaho ike what do you got
i got to say guru hero they were so good
but at the end of the day if i'm picking
one
i'm picking stan's doughnuts baby
[Applause]
some music and look what i love um
ike is that sans is in chicago which is
your hometown
ike baron holtz you are just incredible
and i'm so excited for your new movie
moxie directed by the
phenomenal amy poehler is available
right now
on netflix thank you so much for coming
you made the show so much better and
thank you to stan's donuts
in chicago our battle of the bites
[Music]
winner
you